no I don't remember it but I feel really
cool because I like that I came out of
anesthesia and is like wink to the
camera to a toned look song I mean like
it just makes me feel that I'm like
quietly really cool
I don't know but if I had that sort of
like swagger and real life I just need
to just walk around on anesthesia I
guess that's Blake Lively laughing off
this unforgettable later gram of her
onset injury the 32 year old actress
suffered a hand injury back in 2017
while filming for her soon-to-be
released movie the rhythm section that
day was not my favorite day I mean we
did work that I'm really proud of you
see there's like a four-minute fight in
the in the movie that is that is one
take and no stunt doubles it's just me
and Jude Law but but yeah you know these
things they're not just choreographed
and and you know everything works out
perfectly you guys are really going for
it I'm not sure if it's the take that's
in the movie because I did shoot to the
end so I'm not sure if it's the take is
in the movie but as soon as we wrapped I
went straight to the hospital and then
you know films actually for a couple
more days this was like I'm fine I'm
fine I'm the person who like doesn't ask
for directions and you know I have a
real ego about all that stuff so I was
like it's fine my hands fine and then
after a few days when my hand just like
look like jello I thought you know it's
time to eg caught up with Blake at the
premiere of the upcoming thriller where
she dished on getting into character
this movie is so grounded in humanity
which you don't normally see in this
genre it's people you know beating
people up and shooting guns and getting
into car chases and and there's no
examination of what that must actually
be like to you know come face to face
with another human life and and you know
there are no real good guys or bad guys
everybody's doing what they believe in
and and everyone's just fighting to
survive in these extreme circumstances
and she's not a trained operative she's
not an assassin she's a girl who has
nothing
left to lose and decides that she's
gonna she's gonna fight back and she's
probably gonna die trying but she's
gonna try and I think that that's that
that strength of characters is what
makes this a special is she's terrifying
the whole time because you would be if
you were it have in the middle of this
car chase or in the middle despite you
would be terrified and and read just
most of it most of those big action
sequences are one shot and so there is
no cutting out of it there are no stunt
doubles there's nothing so I'm really
experiencing it as the actor so you as
the audience are really experiencing
it's pretty uncomfortable at points
because you're like cut out show me a
wide shot this is just a really
nerve-racking and I think that that's
that something so really cool but don't
expect to see the blonde bombshell
sporting her everyday look for this role
well our makeup artist Vivian Baker
she's actually nominated for an Academy
Award for bombshell she's so amazing but
it's funny because like I you know was
in a ton of makeup in order to have
these eye bags and and to look as rough
as she looks in the beginning and that
was also in a ton of makeup to look when
she look you know nice and fresh the
real me is somewhere in the middle but
but it's funny and some people see it me
like this is what she looks like without
makeup and it's the horrible one and
then sometimes they're like this is what
she looks like wit without makeup and
it's like the fresh-faced one that also
took an hour so it's funny to see like
you know different people's perspectives
of like how good or how awful I look
without makeup they're all wrong
it's amazing like I think of it like
when you're at my mom's like talks about
how she needs glasses I was like that
sounds really nice it's just like you
probably be really nice to like look in
the mirror and you're like oh this is a
nice filter her eyes are going like
she's like going blind like you know she
just yes but like you know CBS Paris is
nothing serious
[Music]